Hello and Welcome to the last session of the Korea Salty Technologies Agriculture and Catering Symposium
Headquarters Sean is not true about Unit Pretreatment 10 Techniques for Analysis of Pesticide Residues among Agricultural Faults.
There will be about 20 minutes of progress, and there will be a Jirin fishing section between the announcements
.
Ah, if you have any questions at any time during the table, you can leave them in the window
below.
This is Park Jong-yoon, who is so many of the excellent. Today, I will tell you about various pretreatment techniques for residual stress key analysis in agricultural milk.
There are various options for treatment before treatment.
s-pen lee Quetchas
There are various options like this how to use it against the filter firmly.
From the bottom to the top, compared to just filtering, spa becomes the
cleanest sample pretreatment technology.
You can see it as messy and dirty sample pretreatment. It is
more complicated as you go up, and it takes a lot of time and effort, but
it can be seen
as a cleaner sample pretreatment technique.
You can also remove it using sedimentation. In
general, the three sp2 techniques of Eri, who always hit q, are the most widely used
.
I'll give it to
you. Compared to that, solid supporters called sl now have Quiz Ricky Dee's
match test.
There is also a spending method using two liquids that
do not mix. The side is complicated and takes a long time.
Then, in the case of spa, it is in the form of a cartridge like this, so there is
a solid body in it.  It's a relatively solid liquid
phase, so it's called solid state weight.
Then, no matter which technique is used, the purpose of sample preparation is almost the same
.  There is one purpose for cleanup to see, and
another one is not used much in food now, but now it is used a lot for environmental water analysis. It is
the purpose of concentration.  It also has the meaning of concentrating it,
so you can see that the biggest purpose of preprocessing is
refining and soaking.
In particular, among the two foods to be introduced today,
food analysis on food safety is almost now aimed at cleaning up.  It's not
an exaggeration then, you've seen the
most complicated but relatively
clean sample preparation techniques from
bottom to
top.  It is true that the quality of the result increases as the more time and effort is spent
on drilling, the more drilling
is done,
but there is a point where this increase increases to some extent and then slows down
.  So,
in the end, I
can't and can't think of the 4 most appropriate ideas, so I just need to set my sample preparation technology in the most appropriate place
.
under  There is no need to insist on saying yes,
and most of the time, the method at the right time
becomes the notice of the Ministry of Food and Drug Safety.
It is called the special space for high-temperature extraction. The
general protocol is that if the sample is loaded in 5 and 7 months like this, it will stay here and
then go through the washing elution step
.  Since the material is not friendly with the cartridge, it comes off right
away. Then the
blue-colored purpose component stays here.
It can be extracted with an illusion process that can only drop blue.
So, you can simply see the basic protocol of sp as sample loading,
washing, first base shutting down.
When I used it 4,
I could see all the ingredients in the room so well even if I didn't want to see it, so I had to clear the
most appropriate way, but I was able to accurately quantify the pick for my purpose.
So, although it is difficult to do a more accurate qualitative quantification,
you may have a relatively small percentage of whether this is accurate
.
I told you earlier that the default protocol for hp is illusion without nodes
, but this is not always the case because the silver component
may not be well known to the cartridge, and the analytical component may not be
well known to the cartridge.  I don't know, but the sample matrix, that is, the
ingredients in the room may stay well in the cartridge
. Since there are so many different types of sp and so many different mid-class breakthrough compounds and
c matrices, there will be
countless case-by-case cases as to what combination this is.
So  First of all, my analysis father says that pesticides, for example, are not familiar with cartridges,
and goes through the node machine illusion step mentioned earlier.
Of course, the conditioning process must be external before reloading.
Well, you can see that it is the basic probe curry of sp that removes the components in the room where it does not stay due to rest,
and then extracts the purpose of the 4 asterisks that stayed through the elution process
.
When it says it doesn't stay well, it
's just an evaluation.  The
method using this fp technology
is gaining momentum as a pesticide residue analysis method in the Food Codex. It can be seen as
a multi-su analysis method in the Middle East for about 5 minutes
.
If
you look at the ingredients, they are slightly different, but they are almost similar. The front part is the baby axis Liquid
Ricky Destruction first
.
The
protocol is detailed here, but everything on the left that you saw earlier in the transmission head uses the opposite
method of just passing through on the right side of the method of
just passing through on the right
side of the illusion.
this la  Depending on what kind of solvent is used in the elution process, various
method development is possible.
Depending on how it is used, it can be condemned to a much cleaner state
.  I pre-process 100 types of target com
funds, but I can't tell you just one side. So here
, after setting the rules in a way that just texts them or passes them.
Even if it can be a little less clean, it has
the advantage of making the root bee die
evenly with most of the compounds in the
broad range.  Let's take a look at what has changed since Mass Messe was released this time.
Now, free drug analysis, has become so much a bopa that I can't talk about it except for Smith.
Of course, it has become a basic equipment
.  Unlike the pie d of ,
you can pick out only the ping you want and check it in mrm mode.
Therefore, with the advent of mass ms, there is a very great advantage of being
able to accurately qualitatively quantify even if it is not separated to the base line at the same time
.
So uh, even though it is less than three permutation up to Bisrang, qualitative quantification is possible, so it became possible to qualitatively quantify hundreds of trillions
of compounds in a few 10 minutes.
analysis  Instead,
sample pretreatment has not changed much. It is
still complicated and takes a long time. I
tried using my
pretreatment.  That's why the chromatographers took
off their ippune picks The shell casings What you always have to be careful about here is
Originally this big I
'm such a wolf This is this pick So earlier cuv dcf
If you don't want to see the scalpel, you don't have to look
at it
So, the sample preprocessing technology that has been developed since sms 7c becomes a technology called feature meaning. The
how-to technology is
one level lower than spa, as you saw in the thread about sample preprocessing x cleanliness that you saw
earlier, but it is much faster and
A somewhat reproducible example It has become such a sample pretreatment technology that
it is being accepted in many countries around the world. It is also being accepted
in some parts of Korea,
and it is pointed out that Quetzas technology is being accepted more and more
.
Uh sample 8
As you can see, the protocol in the food code is very long, so
it takes a lot more time to do it. It's almost impossible
to do
it.
The first is the extraction step, the second is the purification step,
and then the sample analysis. Let's
start with the first extraction step.
There are many types of extraction kits
.  It's because there are various ingredients in
it.
On the other hand, aoa comment2. There are things like this.
First of all, if you look at the extension part, we
weigh the treatment,
and then weigh it.  Then, if there is an Internet standard,
you can use 1008 at this time, but now Internet stars do not use it.
So, go through this process and
extract it as an nc yen
.  After shaking,
I can't put a yo pouch, that is, a yo pouch containing these substances, into the
leaf extract
. It's busy, and then it's hard up and down.
Up to here, the bottom layer of the extraction is
now with water, and the
solid components of the sample are now settled, and the
upper layer is etched between the aegia cells.
In other words, it is dispurge vs p, so it is
also called dsp
. Splash-up is also composed of
powder.
You
can see that there is a salt to facilitate layer separation.
Then, the particles used for the purpose of the actual competition will come out from now on. It
is called pfa.
It's going to be noticeable
- I'll remove the components that can be disruptive.
I'll do
things like organic acids.  So it's really carbon,
so since it's a raw
material, you can remove many of these pigmented ingredients. So, it's used for the purpose of removing pigments
.  There is a report that it reduces some of the recovery
of id So when you analyze that, it's a little useful
.
In addition to
Petty Cree, which typically eliminates local employment components
, it is called Sudme Matrix Lynn Bury, which is said to be understood. Now, it is
a particle that appears only in the question site.
The instruction with a combination of deep sleep particles The
second dsp becomes a kit. The
way to use
it is
to extract that which has been extracted in No. 8 above
, take acetone of clothes, etc., and
do not spitz it.
Then, if it is vortexed and centrifuged, friendship arises again.
Then, filter it and put it all below,
and the preprocessing for the access pcm sms analysis is finished
. So the club stage is also very simple.
Hey, extraction and purification  In
order to get a little bit of recovery more efficiently and in a quick time, the tool you use is
a tool called 3 amico neck or forget.
A size that can contain the tube
is provided. If
you put these two cell-label nose locks or at the stage of extraction in section 2,
the solid segment of the silver sample and acetone children,
there are children who do not mix well depending on the characteristics of the sample.  there is very strong  You have
to shake it up and down, it's
too powdery and the acetone kids mix well with the eru sample strands,
so it turns gray very intensely up and down and you have to shake it for a long time.
You can see it as a tool that can help with that,
so it takes a relatively short time.  Even when shaken, these things collide very effectively, and you can think of
it as such a device that helps to get caught between the sample and the solvent. If you look at the
actual picture, when the Cera Melk Neck and Rise hanging on the left side of the
was used, the right one was not used.  In other words
, you can see it as the result of the final set fizz. If you want
to separate the left and the right samples equally
, you can see that the old tree has a much cleaner and more accurate
needle separation when the date is written and when it is not.  It can be used.
Earlier, I said that there is also the aoa c method of the big traction key and this anne method.
If you say that the ingredients are a little different and the buffer you use is different, you can say that the
buffer type is different, so the ph is different
.
Among them, there are three methods for simultaneous analysis of free assimilation. This is the
actual method used by the department of the Agricultural Products Quality Management Service.
It says to shake it, but it is not necessary for each one to be re-elected,
and it is provided in case of locky.
5 Each tooth contains the compound by the weight of each tooth in the pouch
, so just touch it and shake it off to become a mummy
.  Next time, extract it like that and analyze it with lcms scalpel immediately. In
the case of Sisi Max Max, additional purification is carried out. 25 mg of pfa and
150 anhydrous magnesium sulfate are in advance.
So, the way to do it in the arms of him is now that the 7 friends and the
dpf fp purification method have been collected in this am strategy, and it is only supposed to be done in 3 cases.
It will be
9 o'clock soon. Next time, there will be no
agricultural products in front of the congratulatory message
.  It is different depending on the paste when doing the uh tissue muscle r, but the
seeds are pretreated. The same used in this cartridge.
The required part number of the air fulfillment method you see here
I used it for
Lit esc Kiss. ​​Simultaneous multi-component analysis of 26 kinds of ava mac tint. Corridor is also a food industry method. Uh, this is also a livestock product church. Uh, it is also extracted here, Kyiv.
Next to the bay,
cat t12
anhydrous magnesium sulfate was used.
Another example is pdp loto ping.
This is a relatively
recent revision and addition.
Let's see, there are so many different Kecha ski poems, so I
put one in the ordering guide and close it, and I feel that the aoa poem
method is the original method.
I'm
going to give you uh basically, I tried mg, and anhydrous always contains magnesium.
Same exact phase separation as the reason why I entered the test of p Kise earlier,
and because she has 6 matching with a water friend,
give it as a tool to make the upper teeth better.  It is also suitable for light
moisture removal apps.
And Mr. aus said that the US law en law is the block law
.
It goes up to o'clock, but no special buffer is
entered.
So, the way we pass after '', the brothers aren't being accepted that much
now. Looking at the trend around the world, and now looking at the trend in Korea
, many of those s are en or aoa c methods.
There are 3 ups, and
the parts without the parts with rabe lumps or yyo as my dad said are each with different
part numbers.
The hanging requirements on the left are tauchi and falcon tubes of 50 mm,
weight 7, and the part number that goes into the
usable falco chichi is a partner here.  It
's okay to call it separately
next time there are also a lot of depot afpk, but I only did some of this now,
and it's actually obtained and used for service analysis among the verbs.
Tish. Here, too, depending on whether the aoa c method or the Lee Haein method
is used, the weight of the compound air is slightly different
.
Woo yes Melo. In
the case of livestock products, 15ml is 3 years old,
so now you can make a ring abyss as you
like.
The part number is assigned to each part
. So far, I have explained Quetzas, and
then again, it is a test site analysis.
I would like to introduce several such applications. First of
all, it is said that there is a lot of fat content. 4 It is a bit difficult in all respects.
But I said that there is always an ingredient in the room,
and please keep in mind that it can always get in the way of every
pick.  I have such a mission to pre-process and remove the fat component as
much as possible
. Even in the tomato recipe, it is about this nc system and
contamination of the column.
It will become a
problem sooner and you have to take a break, so you
will have to go in often.
Next time, give me a mass lobe bar
.  If you look at it, what kind of time you paid is
4 Now you can't do the experiment.
Now, it is a data process.
Due to the ingredients in the room, the actual treatment is not properly processed, so there is a possibility of producing inaccurate results
due to effects such as iron suppression or zinc enhancement
.  In ,
this kind of fat component becomes an
unwelcome guest. You can
see
it as
a table of how much fat content there is from various samples.  It's nothing like this, and it can even be sampled in really oil oil things like this
.
This variety of tf facts
, so we've been experimenting with a variety of dislike matrices containing fat components
3 in particular, this one is okay, but at least 4%  In
the case of a sample containing
fat, the problem as seen earlier that the fat is not clearly removed can
be a
medicine.  It was introduced by 60,
so the emr made by Aejun is a patek called pd, a
size closure, and a hyper abandon interaction.
This 6
purple pack tate is the same, the same as the trip, the same as the lotto, and the same popori skin.
Anyway, these kids who have such a height are spread in this cartridge and
open it as a whole to refine it, and most of my purpose ingredients are
now  Ingredients do not just stay, they come out
. Using that principle, 2
smelts just look like they moved with the cartridge in this forest. I think the same.
3:00 Abe Avocado analysis
One is black, then the entire limit is red using the diss capm and psa you saw before,
and emr is preprocessed with pd and one blue
.
It's not a card, but this is 100% 5 2 2 Again, the
service's edible lipstick action. In this way, you can see that emr cleans the surface of the cleaner with pd and cleans
up in a clean state.
Due to the rapid contamination of mass mass sms, recovery comes out well at first, but as the recognition action is repeated, you
can see that the recovery drops quickly with the cleaner khan, even though there are psa and cat like red like this.
Then, 1 here 30 times  After we inject each other, we
have to do
something cool. There will be a process of washing or cleaning up.
In the case of 100 injections
, there is no change in the size of the e cup.
Then, it has the advantage of being able to take a much longer period of 1 cycle
.  An application note released
on the What Flow was
my introduction to the multi-component pex cytometry analysis among us. Sample cleanup, such as futures + emr leaf, etc. Cleaner was done with
Apple Cleaner Sample Boot Action followed by Water Removal  Until then, we analyzed the main
simath scalpel and affectionate sms analysis. What
we did up to our port was released as an application note.
Let's take a look at it in more detail
. First, take 1
ml of milk.
So I did the x-axis
2 mr to pass through the feed n It has
to contain 20% of water because of the
nature of the cartridge.
I just passed it. The usage of this cartridge is very
simple. I don't need any condition.
I drop the sample containing water into the dry cartridge and
drop it into the middle range.
If the sample was purified
immediately, the more analysis was performed. The
rat Simath Messe was obtained from mg and analyzed after removing moisture
Yoshi.
And
that's the comparison for not doing
uh Here's the installation Matt is a medical
yusukein There's nothing ugly 5 Green pd bones Something's coming out A bunch
of ketchup ply Num said and blue It's long but it's still
there
And now it's the same as a spa tin  I fry the
cleanup together with the carp-caching cartridge in black color.
It has decreased a lot. But there is something that continues to come out little by little here under this. The
red last one is emr's feed cleanup.
It's not an exaggeration, especially the ones that come after the give.
In this land, by reducing the damage to the property by making it very clean, the
recovery of some compounds that did not come out well in the fact side recovery in the rain, which has been a problem
so far  You can see that the
blue half is the result of the pass cleaner version. As you can see, you can
see that some of the quest sizes didn't come out very well.
In this way, there are some ingredients that are not critically ill in any sample.
Then, what are they, especially if it is a matrix problem,
finding a way to effectively remove the matrix is ​​the most accurate
way to obtain results
.  This is the details of the lcms scalpel method used in the analysis. This is a
detailed business. If you look at the
ccm sns analysis results,
this is a measurement of an erotic tube.
The next one was analyzed with 7 8 9 Bombi and 7,000's devices
. Of course, 4 8 9 0 + 701 Gom blood is much stronger than the device configuration.
I'll give you 100 oranges now for 7,000 hours.
And then, with 7010 saliva, you can see much better among professors with 1 error
. A very high-intensity analysis that meets the requirements is possible with just a simple c preprocessing
.  You can see it as such data that says it was done. It
was analyzed with the patty side rcm sms and the chief s mat in the milk you saw earlier
, and it is discarded in the yo-yo result.
Is it within the percentage of? The
right side is a table on rxd above reproducibility
.
too very  With a good level,
you can see that it has been applied to several military police units. 1st trial
fms is better  You can see that rsd is also very good.
For more details
, if you just search our website for the document number called 2938 e, you can download more details about this content as a
criticism method.  It's not, but now it's a fast site
puff in salmon. Hey Chapter 4 g I'll briefly
tell you.  But it is
a positive pusher medical called ppm 48. So, a back-to-manic or
decompression from below to give
a flow, and you can see it as a device that gives flow by nitrogen pressure above the requirements. More simply,
this sp or emr  I think you can understand that there is a kiki that can do this feed
. 3 rice buns. In the case of that sample, I used this tube
.  Most of the time, 70% to 120% 5
Nate can see that they got a good recovery
. There is also a fast side analysis in imitation.
7 Loss 9 Secretion and Chuncheon Raising stocks were
also used, and the column used was the hp pims ui column.
Here, among the boots, all of the various patty sizes are all recovered, and now
the song has been confirmed within a good range.
The curve was also able to obtain a very subtle calibration curve at most pass sites. The
curve range was measured as a norm on the leader of the 1 to 500 nano g cup.
However, you should always keep in mind that you should be able to see the
correct result because is not shown by itself
.
I
've been thinking about it, and it can cause a lot of problems when I don't have proper preprocessing depending on what kind of matrix it is
, so even though it's not visible as mass messe mrm data,
it's always
positioned, isn't it enhanced?
So, you need to select the most appropriate sample preprocessing method in consideration of Odin and other matters
.
Result Confidence in the analysis result can be increased, and
the method to maximize the value behind the ski will be possible from proper sample preparation.
Thank you
App Thank you We will have time for
Q&A
You can confirm it with the request of the Queen of erasure. Could
you read it again?
Even though I was very timid, rather than just taking a picture, you can just take a picture
.  I went in, but it was because of the inner use and the fact that I didn't clean up.
Uh, although the gc-ms scalpel is an acetone eye trap a3, it's okay to just inject it right away
.  It
doesn't matter much Yes
Let's lick the second question on the egg. The question, "How do I wash the ramic?" is good. It's
for Asera Miko's neck or before, so I don't wash it. You can just throw it away
.  He said it should be visible, but he asked how to use it in the case of 100% maintenance.
Uh, in
the case of 100% uc
Then, mix it outside so that the moisture content is 20% with the acetic acid quenching
.
Then, now, liquid yes, I use such a method to call this field. It
is difficult to pass the maintenance itself.
As a rule, it is to pass through the solvent for 20% of the water. So
, the hot recovery came out well, so I turned it
off.
Te 10 a If you have any questions, please enter them in the chat window now.
In the case of
pesticide residue No. 5, 473 species, 81 years, what
kind of zs did you write? It seems that you are talking about drugs that are secretive about the recovery of 473 species, but it is scheduled to be
revised now.
quality sucked  I know that I have tested it by twisting it, and
most of it is now in that range, and now, the component analysis sees 80% to
120% as the range.
Rather than a result, the Ministry of Food and Drug Safety will reach out and use it.
And the last question is from the same person who asked about the use of emr liquid
and the moisture content.
Oh yes, in the old days, for this feed to work properly,
it would be the best sweatware because it was like 20 cells or kids
.  So, there may be many other ways to extract it, but usually, it is the
simplest to do the numerical value
of the recovery
.
Water 22 You can add more water to join and
mix to create an illusion.
Water is essential because it is an activated cartridge.
Thank you.
Again, since there are no additional questions, we will end the secret session here.
There are various product information and
booths that have been organized for zero use.
Please visit us once and you will be sure to visit
us. Our experts are there.
Thank you for your
support. Thank you for being there for a long time.
Thank you.